Sabers from left to right Rangers
in town for the season and away we
go with RJ welcoming everybody inside Key Bank
Center as we honor his fantastic memory and now
the Savers with a first offensive push with
the line of Skinner tuck and Tage Thompson
in the Rangers Zone crowers at bat and [__]
on the line for New York who dump it down into
the Buffalo Zone Deon Levi got a slight touch on
that one Sabers can't clear Miller's shot that
def Flex up lingren trying to find he on the
far wall Sabers chip that one away now panan
trying to go across ice it works as La forier
now with a backhand pass in front of Levi got
over Krebs from the corner along with Genson and
Koso trying to work their way out out power and
Yoki Haru on the back end they'll defend
here shot stopped by Levi rebound scores
rebound the left here banked it into the empty
net and the Rangers take the one- nothing lead
yeah Rangers get a couple good opportunities
here left FR here part of both of them here
on this Rush see the Rangers just attacking here
everything's good right the mer there's a quick
shot Levi makes the save doesn't get the help in
front and the pass is going to quickly come back
across the Grain and SL reier going to that far
post which you want that second man doing he did
it perfectly there got in behind Henry Yoki har
of Deon Levi now it's played back to the point
Guston Far Side for Snider and he thuds that one
off the backboards Sabers with Victor Olson up to
Center Ice Sabers fans urging on now his cousins
on the back hand of the net and churkin comes up
with the stop get in behind gusson here into
the middle right there go to the backand and
he's going to get a clear shot on CER C's got to
come up big right there and he's able to leave
it there and the Rangers AC going power will'll
drop it back for Clifton Skinner through Center
little Juke and a nice shot the pat save made by
shesterkin now it's power below the goal line on
the four on four situation coming up through the
middle here gypson jbes uses the defenseman there
as a screen as he takes that quick shot bery
Schneider goes down he puts it right between
his feet sh cirin has to come up with a big
save there I like he caught it Rangers win
the draw Fox up top sending that towards the net
the Levi saw it on the way able to make the stop
zad Fox top of the far Circle scores crder was
in front of the goal and it's two nothing Rangers
Power Play Go yeah there's no way Levi seen
this I was right in the line here right with
the shot from Fox to Levi you see it right here
Fox he's he's got time everybody's in good spot
right here but you see just at the last second R
where cder he moves and you just could tell the
way Levi goes up and he's he's hoping he gets
a piece of it because he doesn't see it coming
throughing and that's exactly what
happened yeah glad it's over with
cuz they sad they were carrying a lot
of pressure coming in here now they
can relax get to play their game here
a little bit and I think just the way
they ended it Dan and that physical play
that'll get the Rangers to the Buffalo
line he runs out of room Skinner takes it
away from him Krabs left side on the line
here's a shot Johnson off the [Applause]
post panan left side in the Buffalo Zone
late on the play left for nearer makes the
move to the net and Levi has it at the near
post Eric Johnson stepping up right down the
gut of the ice here there's a quick [Applause]
shot Rangers looking for La for and up that
left side that pass is knocked down lrer
stays with it paner it falls to him and he
puts it in the back of the net for a three
nothing Rangers lead with a shot from the
slot and 7el to go here in the second period
panarin here here's the puck over along the
wall and he just kind of pops out into the
middle you got two Savers over in the far side
and that looks like in the middle of the ice
that's disam and kind of play the two-on-one
right here and the quick shot by paner I don't
know what that goes off Samson's like large
drape of the Rangers Jersy on his back and
now here's power up to center with 133 he crosses
the line Power Shot is blocked rebound [Applause]
[Music] scores PKA on the follow
up of the Sabers are on the
board minute and a half power doing a nice
shot getting the puck in there's the first
attempt he takes the shot it's blocked but PKA
right in that slot area right there right in
the middle of all five Rangers gets the
bounce comes right back back to him but
watch how quick soon as that puck hits his
stick bang it's gone it's just cir has no
chance all right we'll see if lemy and little
Ace of Spades doesn't fire up the Sabers coming
out of the tunnel here with a power play for
another minute 15 seconds on attack from left
to right tuck will sweep it around for Tage
Thompson on the far boards up top to darene
near Circle Skinner meets the pass darene Thompson
trying to drift into open Ice they take that away
from him so he's down by the post now he pops
back out to that right Circle Skinner from the
near side wires a shot lost it in the skate
Savers get it back again power from Yoki Haru
and power skates to Center across the Rangers
line with purpose down that Wing threw it to
the net now a stripping a chance for bensson
and at the flex up over the net told them both
to go over and grow up here's green going to
the net he just misses this one middle stats
going to find Rangers don't win the draw kept in
by do 8 seconds to go in the two-man Advantage
paage Thompson dolene Thompson Far Side rips
a shot blocked again Dylan cousins from the
corner heedles out of the box Dalene in the
slot with a shot another block by the Rangers
Dylan cousins minute 39 to go in this power play
darene with a slapper Skinner had an openet off
the end boards couldn't finish it that was
deflected now cousins with a shot block It
Away by shesterkin up into the air and knocked
down by Thompson that shot is blocked again and
it's out of the Zone oh he is hurting and then
run into by anx tuck was lingren yeah lingren
he's paid a huge price here Rangers shorthanded
for another minute 10 and here comes ADV vanage
JB into the Buffalo Zone sends it to the N they
score short-handed goal rder following up on the
pl and it's 4 to one with 826 to go in the third
period blocked shots the story of this Rangers
night right there and then zabad lays this one
out to the front of theet Face Off in the New
York Zone with 135 to go Dylan cousins stands
waiting for mik saan at off the draw Skinner
try to win it back trouba puts it down the ice
towards the empty net and it's in the net for the
fifth of the night for the Rangers the Rangers
captain gets in on the [Applause] scoring in a
battle right here the Sab not able to come
up with this Puck it just poked to Jacob
trouba and he doesn't get a ton on it he just
watching the taco one left wall with 30 seconds
top of the circle Miller stick in the way of
that shot Greenway trying to clear it out of
the corner with 20 seconds to go in the period
Rangers to the far side and Levi got the pat
out pass across kako here Circle and
down to block that one was Johnson 6
seconds to go Savers have the puck
down the ice it goes now'll do it
for this game it's a 5-1 Rangers
win on opening night in Buffalo